[Music]
good afternoon everyone
my name is dr miller and the scp we're
going to be looking at today is scp-3241
[Music]
object class
ketter
special containment procedures sarc is
to continue developing a safe and
effective containment strategy for
scp-3241
until such a strategy exists procedures
to contain scp-3241
will focus on mitigation
observation and the prevention of
outside contact
personnel are to cooperate with the
jmsdf
and other naval aeronautical authorities
to enforce a 75 kilometer exclusion zone
around scp-3241
only foundation-operated vessels are
permitted to enter this zone
surveillance drones are to be deployed
on a weekly basis into scp-3241
to monitor its rate of expansion should
this rate change
scp-3241's current containment director
is to be notified immediately
the use of sras within
scp-3241's exclusion zone is strictly
prohibited pending completion of the
inquiry into the events on november 5th
2015. no personnel foundation or
otherwise are permitted to enter
scp-3241
without o5 approval
description
scp-3241
is an irregularly shaped volume
approximately 12 kilometers in diameter
centered upon the ss sommerfeld formerly
ss chavez it exhibits numerous spatial
temporal molecular and biological
anomalies although the nature and
severity of these anomalies fluctuate
with no discernible pattern they do not
extend beyond scp-3241
scp-3241 is currently expanding at a
rate of approximately 4 meters per day
the ss summerfield is a cargo ship
constructed in 1963
by sun shipbuilding and dry dock company
it was purchased refurbished and
rechristened in 1995 by dls as part of a
foundation-sponsored contract to provide
a transport for low-risk anomalies and
anethesized autokineticists from the
decommissioned site 97 to
site-82 in 1998 the ship was lost along
with its crew anomalies and all five
auto kineticists on board an inquiry
conducted by the foundation in 1999
attributed this to a mid-transit
containment breach followed by the
failed deployment of its emergency
safety system consisting of six linked
sras in 2015 the ss sommerfeld was
discovered adrift 200 kilometers west of
otto island this led to the formation of
sarc to assess the sudden emergence of
scp-3241
and develop a safe and effective
containment procedure for it
in 2018
new evidence came to light regarding
possible malfeasance on the part of
daniel devorne and dls a second inquiry
was conducted into the events of 1998
and 2015. as a consequence of this
inquiry all current and future contracts
with dls have been suspended daniel
devorne remains at large and has been
designated as person of interest 3241
347
addendum 3247 1
loss of the ss sommerfeld
on september 17 1998 the ss sommerfeld
departed jacksonville florida usa for a
tagui rio de janeiro in brazil at 1721
utc the coast guard received a signal
from the ship's epi rb
emergency position indicating radio
beacon placing it near the center of the
atlantic ocean at 1806 utc the epirb
broadcasted another signal placing it in
the vicinity of the sukkote allen
mountain range at 1855 utc cospas sarsat
satellites received a final transmission
from the beacon its position could no
longer be determined all subsequent
attempts to establish communication
failed
early recovery efforts were hindered by
hurricane george's an inability to
determine the ss summer film's location
and dls representatives who incorrectly
insisted to foundation officials that
the vessel was not lost but merely
delayed on account of severe weather
conditions daniel devorne defended this
decision during the 1999
inquiry her emergency beacon was sending
a signal but the coordinates were all
over the place they made no sense
we've had distressed beacons miss fire
before so we figured it was
malfunctioning
we couldn't establish radio contact to
confirm on account of hurricane george's
but after three hours of nothing we
realized something was wrong
that's when i made the call
i called jack myself
i told him something was wrong
i told him that summerfeld had gone
missing
once the ss sommerfeld was declared lost
the foundation immediately mounted a
joint search and rescue operation with
help from undic
united nations disaster assessment and
coordination the goc global occult
coalition united states coast guard air
force air national guard and navy search
efforts concentrated on the ship's
planned route and the two coordinates
provided in its emergency broadcast
after an intensive six-month-long
investigation no trace of the ss
sommerfeld was found
addendum 3241 2
initial inquiry during the initial 1999
inquiry daniel devorne responded to
questions regarding the possibility that
the disappearance of the ss sommerfeld
was caused by a fault in its emergency
sra system
look that's
look i don't want to be rude
but that
that's nonsense
that's absolute nonsense
our scranton reality anchors have a near
flawless track record they've seen
extensive use throughout the foundation
they're directly responsible for
averting disasters every day they save
lives every single day and we're
developing better more cost-effective
sras every single day
what happened to the ss sommerfeld was
tragic but it had nothing to do with our
emergency safety system
what happened was
i don't want to blame your people i'm
sure their performance was exemplary
i've worked with you long enough to know
you only hire the best of the best but i
do want to point out that you
consistently refuse to staff dls
technicians on site to provide immediate
technical support you wouldn't let us
put any of our employees on that boat
you also have a history of
your procedures
have a history of deviating from the
scranton reality anchor manual
the manual exists for a reason
we wrote it
for a reason
if you follow it they work fine
the real tragedy is that this could have
been averted had the foundation been
willing to let one of our dls
technicians on board the sommerfeld i'm
certain they could have correctly
deployed this grant in reality anchors
had the foundation paid for
had you had been willing to take the
time and let our technicians just train
your employees or even read our manual
i'm certain we wouldn't be having this
conversation
professor zoris shetter a paraphysicist
who left the foundation to work for dls
as a consultant corroborated daniel
devorne's claims
i'll never understand the resistance to
scranton reality anchors never we have
we have this wonderful little device
this wonderful miracle that can reduce
even the fiercest of reality benders to
a purring kitten
previously the only bottleneck was their
prohibitive production cost and
maintenance requirements
but now they're cheap self-correcting
and 100 times more potent
i've worked with them for decades
they've saved my life more times than i
can count
if i ask for a show of hands right now
right here in this room of how many of
you have been saved by a scranton
reality anchor i'd be shocked if i saw a
single hand down i really would
what happened to the ss summerfeld was
terrible my heart goes out to the
victims it really does but our scranton
reality anchors have been tested time
and time again
we can account for everything
everything except human error
one voice of descent came from professor
sherman savory a foundation
paraphysicist with a reputation for
expressing skepticism toward sras
all right for starters they don't have a
flawless track record that's a load of
buffers they have a pretty spotty one
actually at best
half the time we can't even tell if they
failed because when they do reality gets
rewritten
scranton reality anchors treat reality
bending as a morphogenic feel they
presume that these fields can be
corrected and that you can unbend
reality and revert the anomalous to a
non-anomalous state
in short sras presume anomalies fit into
a larger system a system we understand
and can control
but what makes something anomalous by
its very definition it's something that
doesn't fit something you can't control
we think we've found a way to suppress
reality ben but all we've really found
is a type of reality bending that's
strong enough to overcome others the
scranton reality anchor is a tiger that
we use to tame other tigers we think
we've domesticated it we think it's our
pet but a pet tiger is still a tiger
you can cage it train it teach it cute
tricks but it's still a tiger
it still has claws and it still has
fangs
and we've surrounded ourselves with them
god help us all if they ever go feral
addendum 3241 3
loss and recovery of the irv silent
spring
on august 12 2015 contact was lost with
the irv silent spring the vessel had
been performing an oceanographic survey
on behalf of odo island's fishing
industry to determine the cause behind a
recent and dramatic change in the
behavior of ceriola quincuerediata
japanese amberjack or yellowtail initial
attempts to locate the ship failed its
transponder was non-responsive or
otherwise outside of effective
transmission range
three days later kansai international
airport intercepted a distress signal
from the irv silent springs epi-rb after
several failed attempts to establish
communication japanese authorities
deployed the errv koyamaru to
investigate this effort was abandoned
when an onboard radiometric sensor
installed in the wake of the 2012
fukushima daiichi disaster detected
small but significant levels of ionizing
radiation from the vessel japanese
authorities then contacted the
foundation who mobilized mobile task
force theta 5 the bigger boat alongside
beta 7 mass hatters to take the irv
silent spring into custody
miguel quinones the acting ceo of mobile
task force beta 7 at the time described
his experience with the vessel during
the 2018 inquest
so when the jmsdf called us we figured
it was just old man jenkins up to no
good happens a lot
some freshly promoted bureaucrat panics
or tries to pass their disaster off on
us we've even had a few cases where
someone tries to make a perfectly normal
problem look anomalous
this one time i heard a guy even
right sorry anyway
we're pretty sure we'd be finding a dead
whale tangled up in a boy or something
we still follow procedure though
complacency is what gets people killed
you learn that lesson day one
came at it upwind to minimize exposure
it's a good thing too this think alone
could have dropped us all
it definitely wasn't a whale but
it didn't look like a boat either
it looked like a giant blob of rotting
meat a spongy
floating meat slab
snoopy picked up some static but not a
lot
we still took every precaution we took a
few extra ones just to be sure
we didn't have any clue what we were
looking at
we didn't even know that there were
people
we didn't know there was anybody in
there
we just hooked it up and hauled it away
figured the lab coats would sort it all
out
the irv silent spring was transported to
a temporary provincial site for
containment and evaluation researchers
soon discovered it previously hosted a
colony of over 300 unidentified species
of microorganisms despite this
microbiome's incredible complexity and
interdependent functionality a mass
extinction event had occurred prior to
recovery
the vessel's exterior was sheathed in an
expired colony of microscopic arthropods
hollow calcium carbonate nodules
extruded from the ship's surface at
multiple points endoscopic and
sonographic surveys determined that they
extended through the hull as part of a
rudimentary respiratory system large
internal cavities of elastic tissue
could expand and contract to regulate
airflow
upon dissection researchers discovered
that the vessel's interior topography
was connected by a complex vascular
system of thin flexible tubing
responsible for the circulation of
nutrients and expulsion of effluent
these tubes extended into the irv silent
springs crew each crew member's central
nervous system had been partially
extricated and fused into a singular
neural mass incorporated into the
vascular system which supplied the brain
tissue with glucose and oxygen the
purpose or function of this congealed
neural mass could not be determined
the module containing the irv silent
springs epirb and vdr voyage data
recorder was found intact the microbiome
had failed to penetrate its exterior
shell however repeated exposure to
ionizing radiation had corrupted the
device's internal memory rendering it
irrecoverable
while retracing the irv silent springs
initial route a foundation-operated
submarine the scpf stravinsky
encountered a cargo vessel adrift two
kilometers west of the odo island japan
the ship had no ais automatic
identification system
did not respond to hails and emitted
significant levels of ionizing radiation
the scpf stravinsky launched a
panopticon class surveillance drone
towards the vessel prior to an
unexplained mechanical failure digital
imagery from the drone confirmed the
ship's markings as a match for the ss
sommerfeld
addendum 3241
4
initial response
on october 26 sarc was assembled to
assess the extent of the ss sommerfeld's
threat and develop an effective
containment strategy for it brian
browning a veteran foundation field
agent and site 97's former site director
was assigned as containment director
close observation of the ss sommerfeld
was all but impossible on account of its
unpredictable properties surveillance
drones sent into its area of effect
experienced numerous mechanical failures
in order to acquire more data director
browning requisitioned several sras from
dls and ordered them mounted inside the
scpf stravinsky the submarine was to
approach scp-3241
under the cover of a morphogenic field
an attempt to retrieve its vdr
several members of the scp-f
stravinsky's crew refused director
browning's orders this group included
the vessel's executive officer leslie
horton she explained her decision in
2018.
browning painted us as a bunch of
traitors attempting a coup but anyone
with a [ __ ] iota of military
experience will tell you there's a world
of difference between open fire and walk
up to the enemy and tweak his nose while
a magic box protects you besides this
wasn't a military operation there was no
immediate threat
we had every right to stop work over
safety concerns and that's precisely
what we did
professor box she was the reason why
though bakshi had experience with sra's
real experience he didn't trust them he
told browning that his plan would put us
at risk when browning told him to piss
off bakshi came to us directly he
explained these things the sras he told
us they were unreliable described it
like trying to put out a fire with a
flamethrower sometimes it works
sometimes you just burn the whole
goddamn neighborhood down
convinced me at least
browning was furious
kept ranting about how bakshi didn't
know the first thing about field work or
paratech
he said that if boxy didn't have the
stomach for this sort of thing then he
ought to i think his exact words were go
apply for a job managing a 7-eleven
and then he said some some other things
that i um
won't repeat
here
but but in the end boxy wouldn't back
down and neither would we
a compromise was reached on november 5th
one sra would be mounted to a usv on
man's service vehicle capable of
sustaining its weight and supplying it
with power a representative from dls
arrived as an sra consultant and to
provide technical support
shortly after entering scp-3241
area of effect the usv ceased to respond
to remote commands the vessel operated
autonomously for two kilometers before
experiencing a catastrophic mechanical
failure and sinking along with the
mounted sra as this was significantly
farther than what previous drones had
achieved the dls representative claimed
that the sra had worked furthermore he
claimed that control over the drone had
likely been lost on account of the sra's
morphogenic field not being wide enough
to prevent anomalous disruptions of
incoming radio transmissions he
concluded that a network of overlapping
sras combined with adjustments made by a
licensed sra operator would be more than
sufficient to overcome any of scp-3241's
anomalous effects
director browning agreed with this
assessment he again ordered the crew of
the scpf stravinsky to mount sras into
their vessel and proceed into
scp-3241's area of effect with professor
bakshi the only licensed sra operator
present at the time on hand to make
adjustments as required again several
members of scpf's stravinsky's crew
refused
director browning then ordered three of
the five remaining sras to be mounted on
the scpf beagle iii a small four-man
patrol boat and assembled the team to
personally accompany him to
scp-3241's area of effect when professor
bakshi refused to accompany director
browning he asked the dls representative
to fill professor bakshi's role instead
in 2018 professor gampir bakshi gave the
following testimony regarding director
browning's request for the dls
representative to operate the sra
raymond asakawa
the technician from dls that was his
name
he was young
very young
very bright too
i found out later that he was studying
to be a computer scientist he just
worked this job to pay his tuition
i don't think he
i know he didn't intend to mislead
anyone
he just trusted his training
he trusted the sra manual
all his answers to director browning's
questions came straight out of that
manual he must have memorized it
director browning ate it up
pattied the young man on the back asked
him all about hume levels can't counters
questions he knew mr asakawa could
answer
building up his confidence making him
feel like an expert like
like part of the team
then when dr browning asked me to
accompany him he knew i would say no
he knew
he turned to mr asakawa and that's when
i realized what was going on why he had
been treating this young man so nicely
he was playing with him
he turned to asakawa and said
he asked
if he if he could
he
he asked
him
he asked him to [ __ ]
sorry i'm
i'm sorry i don't usually
i need i need a moment just
just give just give me a moment it's
been a long time since i've talked about
[ __ ]
i'm sorry
oh okay
all right okay i'm all right now sorry
sorry for the cussing
he looked so scared right then
mr asakawa i mean
i think he was starting to realize there
was a very real danger here but then
browning said something i don't even
remember what
something about how back in the day they
didn't have scranton reality anchors how
they could have saved so many lives back
then how important asakawa's work was
something like that then asakawa smiled
and
he he was looking at me before when he
was scared
he was looking straight at me
me like he was expecting me to save him
and
i could have
i could have saved him
i could
i could have said
no
i could have said absolutely not i could
have pulled that boy off the boat and
told that fat racist [ __ ] to go [ __ ]
himself
but i didn't
i was so angry at him
ronnie put his pride before all of our
lives
i wanted him to be punished
he deserved to be punished
and that's why raymond asakawa is dead
he asked me to save him and i didn't
because i was angry
i'm not sorry that browning is dead
[ __ ] him
he deserved worse
but i am sorry about raymond asakawa
a day doesn't go by that i am not sorry
about raymond asakawa
i let that happen
i let that young man die
it should have been me on that boat
i'm sorry
[ __ ] i'm sorry
god i'm so sorry
director browning boarded the scpf
beagle 3 with his team and approached
scp-3241 out of the four team members
only jacksonville cola a veteran
containment specialist survived
we were about half a kilometer in when i
realized something was wrong it was this
low keying noise behind me like
something was off with the engines
i started thinking about what i'd do if
they went belly up couldn't risk
swimming for it then i remembered the
toll line
they could reel us back
then relaxed me a little
but that sound just kept getting louder
and louder
something felt off about it too shrill
not mechanical enough
i finally turned around and
yeah
wasn't the engines
it was a kid
the one dls sent us
he'd been screaming for a while now
it wasn't hard to see why
what surprised me was that he could
scream
big chunks of him had turned into glass
you could see straight inside him like
somebody installed a bunch of windows
all over his body
there was this web of veins that wove
through his guts like pink silk ribbons
when he moved it made this horrible
noise
crackling and popping like someone
grinding their heel down
into a sack of light bulbs the glass
started splintering
jagged lines shot through him
and bit into his innards blood trickled
along the cracks and then dribbled out
of him
real slow
sanchez had turned inside out
he didn't seem to mind
i think he even winked at me
and browning
uh i'm not positive but it looked like
his bones were evaporating his body was
collapsing into a heap of loose folded
skin like a pile of dirty laundry
this foul-smelling yellow smoke kept
pouring out of his holes
i think the engines croaked at some
point
the last thing i remember was them
hauling us back as fast as they could
that's when i passed out from the pain
when i woke up a few weeks later they
told me that sanchez and browning were
dead on arrival
the kid took about 20 minutes to finally
shatter and bleed out as for me
got pretty lucky only lost three limbs
and half of my intestinal tract
look browning was the son of a [ __ ]
i'll give you that he and i joined the
foundation during the glory days
we did things differently back then and
when the times started changing he
couldn't change with them he was my
friend yeah he was also a [ __ ] human
being
i know that
i've always known that
but for all his faults he's not the
reason i now drink my meals through a
tube and [ __ ] them into a bag
i don't blame the kid either
he wouldn't have come along for the ride
if he didn't swallow this scranton
reality anchor horseshit just like the
rest of us
and i sure as [ __ ] don't blame gambier
boxy as far as i'm concerned that man is
a goddamn saint
but daniel devorne
i swear to god
if i ever lay eyes on that man i will
crawl out of this wheelchair and rip his
[ __ ] throw it out with my bare teeth
it didn't do a goddamn thing
you hear me not a god damn thing
if anything it made things worse
none of the drones flipped inside out
none of them evaporated in the smoke
none of them turned into [ __ ] glass
no
they all just broke
it wasn't until we tried using his
shitty products to contain a shitty boat
that i ended up in this shitty chair
wherever you are dr devorne you want to
get down on your knees and thank god
almighty that the foundation has
changed because back in my day
this story wouldn't end with some sort
of
some sort of [ __ ] inquiry it would
end with you in an orange jumpsuit
thrown in the deepest darkest hole we
could find
it would end with us laughing while we
sipped ice-cold beers
and made bets on how long it'd be before
all our monsters
got tired of your screams
addendum 3241
5
recovered emails
on january 3rd 2018 an anonymous source
provided the foundation with several
terabytes of data taken from dls's
intranet this data included numerous
email exchanges between daniel devorne
and his staff in regards to the
installation of the emergency sra system
in the uss sommerfeld
date
1604-1995 subject regarding emergency
sra system
from simon chelkov to daniel devon
we can argue that correlation does not
equal causation until you're blue in the
face than but the correlation is
one-to-one across the board for over 10
years
and even if it didn't correlate it
doesn't change the fact that every
anchor out there including the ones that
have been in service for decades are
experiencing failure events with
increasing regularity every new sra we
put into service increases the risk of
another sra failing
right now
we are accounting for these increases in
failure rates by an automated correction
system
when one unit fails two can adjust their
morphogenic fields and suppress the
faulty unit
before it goes critical we schedule
monthly preventative maintenance to
check for faulty units
and quietly swap them out for other ones
that won't turn your skin into acid or
whatever but that's just it
you need at least two clean units to
stop a failed unit from going critical
which is why an emergency system with
only four sras just isn't going to cut
it anymore that setup would have worked
20 years ago sure
back when a single unit failure was a
rare occurrence but now
multiple units in a set fail all the
time and if two out of four fail the
other two won't be able to hold them
back they'll go critical have you ever
seen a scranton reality anchor go
critical
i have
words like biblical come to mind if you
want this ship to be safe
you'll need 18
at least 15 units
that will keep them out of the danger
zone that makes the changes of a
criticality event all but impossible
install just one unit less and you'll be
putting everyone on board in harm's way
following a review of these emails
foundation investigators concluded that
the loss of the ss sommerfeld likely
occurred as a result of a critical
failure with its six on-board scranton
reality anchors furthermore
investigators went on to link over 20
separate containment breaches to similar
critical sra failures this led to the
2018 inquiry into the loss of the ss
sommerfeld and the foundation's ongoing
reliance on sras for the containment of
onto kineticists
two weeks prior to the start of the
inquiry daniel devorne escaped
foundation custody
efforts to locate him are underway
this concludes today's lecture
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
i would like to give a special thank you
to
aletraon
zargaran
professor puffer
retalias
jk
signor
your local foundation agent
derivative
gabriel hawkins
nate decline
lost boy
a real american hebrew
[Music]
eric corbin
longinus
karim l ashmoy
james saba
and nj vojak
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com
forward slash thevogen
thank you
you